- Ranger Zickle, "They say
there are no dumb questions,
"but why do I still feel dumb asking it,
"also, is that a wall behind you?"
Ginger, "Next time you do
answering your medical questions,
"could you please tell me,
"why I can feel an invisible
pair of glasses on my face?"
Is it because you normally wear glasses,
and you think yours are still on?
I need more, Ginger give me more, Ginger.
Tetrisi, tetris is my, TetrisizMiGame,
I don't know why I put a
little lisp on there, question,
"Why do your taste buds go
crazy when you're sick?"
I don't think it's so
much your taste buds,
I think when you're sick
your nose gets congested,
so you can't smell properly,
and a big factor on
how you perceive taste,
comes from your ability to smell foods.
So when your nose is congested,
and your aren't properly
smelling the foods,
you also can't taste them well.
I'm sure there's also something to be said
about the inflammation that's going back,
going on in the back of your
throat, and your tonsils,
that could potentially
also cause a problem
for you and your taste buds,
maybe make them a little
bit less sensitive.
And also, if you have a congested nose,
you're more likely to
mouth breathe at night,
which dries everything up,
can also affect your taste
buds, multifactorial answer.
Noranjo, question to Doctor Mike,
"Is it true, that it is
better for your digestion,
"if you don't drink while eating?"
I have not seen this substantiated.
I actually enjoy drinking
while I'm eating,
and I don't mean drinking alcohol,
I mean drinking liquids like water,
I feel like it helps
me move the food along,
I think it's something
we recommend as doctors.
Also, drinking water will
actually expand your stomach,
and make you feel fuller,
so it maybe encourage you to eat less.
Viccy Pryce, "Okay here's my question,
"how are you a doctor with a
strong gag reflex, explain."
I don't know, I've managed to control it.
It's tough, but with
time you gain experience,
and you learn how to meditate away
your fears, and uncomfortableness.
Megan Deoden, "Hard-hitting question."
That's the only kinda questions I want,
on my responding to comment section.
"What does Bears diet look like?
"What is your favorite brand of dog food,
"and what is his favorite treat?
"What is his cheat snack?"
First of all, Bear is an
absolute vacuum cleaner.
Whatever I put in front of
him, he just goes (scrunches).
Sometimes I feel like
he forgets to swallow,
because, swallow, he forgets to chew.
Recently his favorite
snack has been lamb ears.
But, something that I always do,
is I always give Bear carrots.
He loves chewing on carrots,
they're healthy, safe for dogs,
and I give him like four
or five baby carrots,
and he's like the happiest
newf in the world. (hisses)
Tom Hutch Videos 96, "Can chest
compressions stop the heart,
"if the heart is already beating?"
First of all, I'll answer this
question in a different way,
not the way you probably wanted it.
Don't do chest compressions
if someone's heart's beating.
The purpose of doing chest compressions,
is when the heart's not beating.
I guess you're asking if you aren't sure
if the heart's beating, well look,
if the person's completely unconscious,
and they're not breathing,
odds are their heart's not beating,
so go ahead and do chest compressions,
call for help first, of course.
Janine Fernando, What's your
opinion on split-sleeping,
"two to three hours in the morning,
"five to six in the
evening, is it healthy?"
I don't like it, yes there is some benefit
to taking a little siesta when
your circadian rhythm dips,
in the midday phase, but I
think split-sleeping like that,
just, I don't see evidence for it.
What I see evidence for is
sleeping seven, to nine hours,
of consistent steady sleep,
of the same time at night,
and then if you need to,
taking a short 15 to 30-minute
nap in the middle of the day,
when your circadian
rhythm takes a little dip,
around one, two p.m.
Now we just got a get those napping pods,
in all our offices, then we'll be all set,
and actually get our bosses
to allow us to do the nap.
Arrow Jade, "I have a very
random, and interesting question,
"is the study of dreams,
and how they work,
"a profession on its own?"
I don't know if it's a
profession on its own,
but I know there are
certain psychologists,
and even psychiatrists,
who do study the interpretation of dreams.
There's definitely like a name to this.
Study of dreams.
I can learn something too in this video.
It's called oneirology,
oneirology, oneirology.
The study of oneirology
can be distinguished
from dream interpretation,
in that the aim is to quantitatively study
the process of dreams, instead
of analyzing the meaning.
Myrkr Ormr, "Serious question,
"if EKG means electrocardiogram,
then wouldn't it be ECG?"
It actually is ECG, EKG is
sort of the old-school name,
from the German definition
elektrokardiographie, with a K.
But now we do call that an ECG,
in fact when I order on my computer,
I can either put EKG, or
ECG, doesn't really matter.
See ECG, so we do call it ECG.
Greg Lidal, "Is picking your nose bad,
"outside of the risk of
spreading germs, et cetera?"
Greg, this is a great question.
A lot of people pick their nose.
I think I've seen studies
go up as high as 90%,
of individuals at one point
in time, pick their nose,
and I'm sure it's more than
that, they're probably just...
That last person being, "I
don't wanna tell anybody."
There are issues when you pick your nose,
first and foremost, trauma.
The inside of your nose,
is more sensitive than
the outside of your nose,
so by going inside in
there, picking in there,
especially with your
fingernails, cause trauma,
cause nose bleeds, especially
recurrent nose bleeds,
because it takes forever for
that area to properly heal.
On top of it, your
fingers, aka your digits,
are the dirtiest, meaning
the most bacteria,
and viruses live on these bad boys,
so when you're putting them in your nose,
where your mucous membranes are,
that's a surefire way to get sick.
In fact, one of the
biggest things I recommend,
for people to avoid catching the flu,
is to wash their hands, a, and then B,
to not touch their face.
Means going in the nose.
One of the most important
methods to break a habit,
like nose picking, if
you just have a habit,
and you're not compulsive and doing it,
put something on your
finger like a bandage,
that you use primarily
to pick your nostril,
because when you do it,
you're gonna remind yourself,
that oh I shouldn't be doing it,
because otherwise it
can become really easy
to just keep doing it,
and please, don't go from
the nose, to the mouth after.
Grovia Springham, "If this old lady,
"can run her first half,
at 55, you can do it,
"two hours is not out of the question
"for a healthy young guy,
good luck, you got this."
I appreciate the support
Grovia, and seriously,
amazing job, doing a half marathon at 55,
amazing job doing a half marathon, period.
Forget about your age.
if you haven't seen this,
I'm gonna link it down below.
Nike and I have teamed up,
to try out one of their
new running sneakers,
and I'm gonna be running in
the LA 13.1 Half Marathon,
in a month and a half, and
I'm training right now,
but it's a struggle.
I'm essentially going
from being a sprinter,
to a half marathon
runner in like 10 weeks.
For someone who has
never ran long distance,
that's really tough, and I'm 200 pounds.
These think thighs save
lives, but hold me back
when it comes to running
marathon, you jive?
Achereds, "Is it possible that one day,
"medicine will not be effective anymore,
"since diseases like
the flu keep evolving,
"and getting stronger?"
The flu does not necessarily get stronger,
it just continually evolves,
in order to keep surviving,
that's what sort of nature's all about,
that's how we came to be.
There will be certain medications
that will become less useful, yes,
but at the same time, we'll
create new medications,
we'll learn new methods
of fighting off viruses, and bacteria.
In fact one of the main
reasons why we recommend
to not overuse antibiotics,
is to decrease this
resistance that's forming.
I have patients that I've
treated in the hospital,
that they have bacteria, that's resistant,
to every kind of antibiotic
that I can offer them,
that's called a multi-drug
resistant organism,
and that's quite dangerous.
We don't want these
superbugs anywhere near us.
So let's not take antibiotics
when we don't need them.
"When doctors ask about if
you've been sexually active,
"what counts, for medical purposes?"
Anything involving the
genital region should count.
If it doesn't, but you
still think it does, say it.
There's no harm, more
information is always better,
when it comes to doctors visits.
La Anonymous, "Can you get a gallstone
"as a result of stress,
after you lost your job,
"had a loved one pass, et cetera.
"Thanks for answering, love your channel."
Thanks for the love, you can
get a gallstone any time.
A lot of times, we don't
even have a good reason
as to why they happen.
Obviously, eating an unhealthy diet,
full of fried, fatty foods, is not ideal,
and when one is stressed,
you tend to eat more of
those types of foods,
so that can be a trigger,
but in general we don't
have great evidence
as to why it happened,
in that specific moment.
The same way that, you
know, when you get a cold,
or the flu, can ask me all
you want, "Why did I get it?"
I don't have an answer, it just happens.
The Lorax, "Mike, there is no
such thing as a dumb question.
"Me, how much feet are in seven minutes?
"Yes, or no."
No.
I don't know why, but it's no.
Think about that Lorax.
BlacknWhite, "I have a question,
"how do I send fan art to Dr. Mike?"
PO box, baby,
which I haven't checked in
a while, I probably should.
It's listed down below, it
says, "please send me stuffs".
Domagoj Lovosevic, "Since
higher body temperature's
"a good thing when fighting viruses,
"at what temperature should
you take medicine to lower it?"
There's no specific temperature,
where there's like a cut-off.
If you're becoming really uncomfortable,
you can't sleep, and rest, and recover,
that could also be an indication to do it.
In general, if I have a
low fever, 100.5 to 102.5,
I tend to stake it out as much as I can,
just because that will help my body
fight off the infection
a little bit better.
But again, if you're uncomfortable,
might need to take something.
Roni. bm, "Here's a question,
"do you wax your hands, or something?"
Wax my hands?
No I do not wax my hands,
that would be strange.
Cells at Work is finally back,
after my copyright challenge,
so click here to check it out.
If you want me to do a second episode,
definitely let me know, while
staying happy and healthy.
(funky music)